we've got coming to Disney plus secret
Invasion okay
it is an honor to say that finally
guardians of the galaxies
I Wish I Was Here shooting right now
Lord hear you screamed for Disney plus
Echo
I'm so excited characters we're in
Productions
is My Season Two my number two the film
that we announced at the end of our last
panel
I just want this movie to happen at this
point October
[Applause]
we have a series on Disney plus this is
very special it is going to be an 18
episode oh yes 18 episodes no way no way
you guys gotta turn that down born again
[Applause]
welcome back to New rockstars as we wait
for Guardians of the Galaxy we started
thinking what are Marvel's most
anticipated phase five projects is it
Loki season two is it Guardians of the
Galaxy is a secret Invasion today me and
Mt will talk about every MCU phase five
project in which we think is crucial in
building up to phase six and what we me
and Mt are most excited for this is
inside Marvel new rockstars weekly
Marvel reaction show I'm Jessica Clemens
here with me today is MTV bro I am so
excited for phase five phase five is
going to be like a huge huge huge step
into like this Multiverse narrative we
saw with quantumania it was chapter one
and kings are coming and um like my
goodness I'm so excited to see how like
all the Kane factor into like the the
more Street side of marble like you're
Captain America's your Daredevils
because you know they're gonna they're
gonna creep into every single corner so
I'm very excited to see how they and
that's how I feel with secret Invasion
I'm like we have the Kings and then we
also have the secret Invasion coming so
it's like how are these two gonna be
such major factors I know Kang is going
to be the ultimate big bad but it's like
secret Invasion will play a lot because
there's gonna be people that we didn't
know are actually not who we think they
are and it's uh to go exactly people who
we trust and who we should have never
trusted should be Janet watch it be
Janet once Janet came out like
I'm okay we'll get into it we will get
into it in a second but first but first
we are oh we're gonna get into this be
sure to check out nerd riot.shop where
you can always grab the latest and
greatest new rockstars gear right now
you can check out our new line of merch
inspired by the Mandalorian season three
support the channel check out our great
merch options over at nerdriot.shop and
don't forget to subscribe to our newest
Channel The Deep dive Eric just dropped
this back to the Future deep dive and
let me tell you hey I'm obsessed with it
uh though I my my first original fandom
was Back to the Future I thought I was a
fan yes I freaking love I love all the
back to the Futures and I thought I was
a fan until I watched uh Eric's Deep
dive of it so be sure to go to the
channel support it go watch it Eric is
the time travel Maestro man so like this
is exactly he is literally the craziest
time traveling robot man I've ever met
uh and if you're planning on if you're
planning to be at WonderCon this year
March 24th new rockstars will be doing a
live panel on Friday at 2 30 p.m that's
March 24th a day before my brother's
birthday uh we'll be doing fun live
shows completely different than anything
you've seen before on the channel so be
sure to stop by and say hi this Friday
March 24th at 2 30 at WonderCon I'll be
there Zach will be there Eric Voss will
be there uh Tommy will be there Mt will
be there in spirit and so will others
yes yes
will also be there so come on down we'll
sign your baby's foreheads all right
Jess the big question for today is um we
got to talk about it what projects are
[Music]
upcoming phase in Phase five oh my God
this is a this is actually the biggest
question we could ever ask on the
channel so phase five
with quantumania and essentially ends at
Thunderbolts which is expected in summer
of 2024. after Quantum Mania and secret
Invasion Guardians of the Galaxy uh Echo
Loki the Marvel's blade ironheart Agatha
coven of chaos Daredevil Captain America
New World Order and then the
Thunderbolts uh which projects do you
think the fans are most interested in
and what other projects you think we're
most excited for and I think oh God I
want to say deep down in my heart deep
down in my heart I am most excited for
the Marvels but I think Captain America
New World Order is gonna be one of the
most excited projects for this uh phase
five absolutely I think that it's it's
good to be hyped for both because like
both of these movies are going to be
massive films that push the MCU forward
in like their two respective Realms
because like the Marvels is going to be
more Cosmic um we're gonna see the the
Marvel ladies go probably go off into
space most likely and um you know
Captain America New World Order is
America in like the in the world and
stuff so like we have two separate
Realms of the MCU that are um going to
be affected and like I have a huge huge
feeling and like there are rumors going
around that blue Marvel is going to show
up in uh the Marvels and I cannot wait
can you remind the audience who blue
Marvel is blue Marvel is a man by the
name of Adam Brashear and he it was one
of the most powerful heroes in the
earth's distant past like in the 60s or
whatever and um like he was like going
around like being a hero until they
found out that this dude was black and
uh everyone was having a hissy pick
because it was during the racist times
and the president was like yo well you
gotta stop being a hero and uh because
the people are going too crazy and so he
did and then he came back and um he's
like to this day he's like one of the
most powerful
um heroes in the in the Marvel Universe
but yeah he did leave the ultimates team
for a while which is one of my favorite
Comics
um both of those um two the first two
volumes
um were one of my favorite runs within
so yes he's one of the biggest Heroes I
believe that in the MCU blue Marvel will
be a woman I'm saying that right now
um because the Marvels is a a um a take
on the Marvel let's like that band
um Nick Fury uh does a little tease at
the end of Captain Marvel it's like yeah
like the Marvel like The Marvelous and
like because they're a band of like
three I think there was four women at
the time at one time but yeah I think
each of the Marvels are supposed to be
at the mcu's take on the Marvel let's
and so uh blue Marvel will be the fourth
uh Marvel at
um in that team that will be revealed to
be Alouette Alouette was like this
the like mysterious figure that Carol
and Monica both looked up to you in
Captain Marvel and like she supposedly
went off into the sky to fight a uh some
type of cosmic
um shaking in the universe and I think
that that Alouette was supposed to be
blue Marvel anyway I'm talking about no
you're good that's the market it's
important because I also I think during
one division we were so stuck on uh
Monica meeting blue Marvel in one
Division I was I I thought the the
scientist the doctor she was always
going to meet up with was going to end
up being Blue Marble right so I would
love bro like I was sort of feel like so
I was like I would love blue Marvel to
show up uh I think the audience
especially at um the Comic-Con were very
vocal about their favorite and most
anticipated being Daredevil born again
uh which makes sense because this is the
first Netflix series moving on over to
Disney plus and it's getting 18 episodes
or at least over eight which is what we
normally get from Disney Plus shows yeah
like Marvel Studios committing to an 18
episode series like the actual Studio
versus like Marvel TV this is huge this
is going to be like a phenomenal project
it's going to be a lot different from
the Netflix show as uh Vincent D'Onofrio
has said on Twitter recently it's gonna
be a lot different feel but like it's
still going to be amazing because this
is Marvel Studios the same people that
made the Winter Soldier remember that
people we're getting Winter Soldier
quality added to Daredevil so be excited
everyone do you think um and then
recently they've released that the
Punisher is going to be coming into uh
Daredevil born yes so sorry my voice
because I am very excited John Bernthal
was born to play this role he was born
to be the Punisher
um I feel like this is more so a
documentary than anything
um because this just feels so real uh
just kidding uh but no I'm very excited
to see
um him and uh Charlie Cox came up
together again because season two
Daredevil was incredible would you say
now with the Punisher being in that this
is the most anticipated project for
phase five this is not based off of like
what's in it not necessarily like how it
uh affects the Kang Dynasty or phase six
but do you think because the Punisher
because Charlie Cox because Vincent
D'Onofrio are coming into the MCU
Disney's MCU do you think that would
make this the number one most excited
project for everybody absolutely
absolutely I think like the number one
most fan anticipated project is
Daredevil born again because like people
were campaigning so hard for Daredevil
to return in general and for uh Marvel
Studios and Kevin feige to listen to the
fans and to bring back Charlie Cox and
Vincent de alfrio and um you know like a
lot of the Defenders we know the
Punisher is coming back
um there's hints of
um Luke Cage and and um Jessica Jones
potentially coming back it's not a
but I'm like okay if the because okay so
a couple months ago almost maybe a year
ago The Punisher John barenthal's
trainer was training John barenthal and
posted on Instagram a picture of him and
him training and being like The Punisher
is back baby or something like that and
people are like oh maybe he's just
getting our goat and then here he is and
Jessica Jones the actress that plays
Jessica Jones uh Kristen Ritter and the
guy that plays Luke Cage we're hanging
out too and I was like oh my God so
maybe there is something that we're not
just seeing fully yet through these
Instagrams that I am dissecting but I
think it's a possibility I think it's a
high probability yeah I think it's a
very high probability too because if
you're gonna bring back Charlie Cox you
might as well just bring back
um all the main Defenders
um and I think what what's super
exciting for me about um the punisher's
inclusion into the MCU is that of the
way is the specifically the way the
Punisher season two ended with um him
getting a call from madani who now works
for the CIA and now that we know that
Val is in charge of the CIA and like
there's a connection there uh we could
potentially see
um that connection leading the Punisher
towards the Thunderbolts which would be
super super dope and um a very Comics
accurate yes yes because he is so
because because Daredevil born again we
as fans are yes extremely excited I
would put that as our number one what do
you think would be the second one that
everyone's most excited for I would say
probably
hmm
uh Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. I
think that you know I agree I agree this
is the the end of the series and like
Guardians movies never you James can do
no wrong with that series like he puts
so much of his heart and soul into
writing those movies and like you know
the character of Rocky he said in the
past that um it's very he's a very
personal character to James Gunn
specifically and so like knowing that
James Gunn is like leaving the MCU to
leave the DC the DCU to Greatness it's
gonna be amazing
um like knowing that that's gonna happen
I it's gonna be super super emotional
seeing this rocket story
um reflects sort of like the end of both
rocket and
um James guns like time with um this
guardian's family so yeah no it's going
to be super emotional and everyone loves
the Guardians those movies sell super
well so I would say number two is
guardians but that's what that's what I
think but then I'm also like I think
it's really Thai with Loki because Loki
season one was so phenomenal yeah yeah
yeah my God you're totally right because
Loki season one ended with the biggest
Cliffhanger ever and then the same
quantumania's little uh their stinger is
like Victor timely directly tied in a
cliff probably directly taken from
season two of Loki so I'm like yeah but
like Loki was the one to kick off the
Multiverse Saga like Loki and Sylvie
specifically were were the ones just
like because without them there would be
there would be no Spider-Man no way home
there would be no Multiverse of Madness
um there would probably be no
quantumania the way that it happened so
yeah like Loki is season two is gonna be
incredible I cannot wait for a trailer
so I would yeah I would say you're
probably right that's probably number
two yeah
um and I would probably put Guardians
number three next yeah uh but I don't
know what do you think is different I
think yeah I think the top three are
Daredevil Guardians and Loki for sure I
think Loki is number two as well I think
I agree with you wholeheartedly I want
to put Guardians and look at the same
like the same tier because it's also
guardian's last one that we're seeing so
it's like yeah you're gonna wanna see it
you're gonna want to see this one but
Loki season two is like this
is very crucial which is honestly the
next topic we're getting into so I want
to hold it I want to hold what I'm
actually fully about to say about Loki
season two yeah and let's let's start
moving into the second discussion let us
know in the comments right now what
you're most excited for in Phase five
not what you not what you think is
crucial what you genuinely are looking
for what you're most excited for rooting
for would buy a t-shirt of because that
means you're a true fan if you buy a
t-shirt for it
let's get into it let's talk a little
bit about the sponsors that bring inside
Marvel to you yes let us talk about
Helix sleep one of our wonderful
partners that sponsor inside Marvel
while we dream about our favorite phase
five projects we want to do it on the
best mattress possible and here in new
rock stars we love our sleep time with
Helix as we have for many years Helix
makes premium mattresses and bedding
that are customized to fit your needs
and conveniently shipped right to your
door which Helix mattress is right for
you don't worry about it Helix made a
sleep quiz that matches your unique body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you based on
different sleep positions and firmness
preferences they have something for
everyone's unique taste if you sleep
with a partner you can take that sleep
quiz together and find something that's
the perfect compromise for both of you
the best part about all this is that
Helix delivers your mattress right to
your door with free shipping in the U.S
plus Helix has a 100 night sleep trial
so you get more than three months to
make sure that you love it or you get a
full refund Helix mattresses have a
10-year warranty and they even offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix and I think you
would too if you're looking for a new
bed check out Helix today you can click
this link below or go to helixsleep.com
inside Marvel to get 20 off your Helix
mattress plus two free pillows we're
giving you two free pillows with this
that's helixsleep.com inside Marvel now
it is time for our second question of
this inside Marvel which project from
phase five would you think is the most
crucial to phase six we're looking extra
ahead okay so I think all these projects
of phase five are very important to
phase six and storyline probably and
definitely an individual characters but
I'd say especially as an example Loki
season one was very crucial for phase
five right uh in phase four it was like
oh he's the reason Kang is like
now overall he's not the reason but like
Sylvie killing Kang released a bunch of
other gangs and we wouldn't have known
that oh yeah they basically you just
ruining the Multiverse so it's like that
I think Loki season one is required
viewing in order to know king and the
King variants to know where it really
started so Loki season two I think is
the most crucial thing that you will
need to watch in Phase five to that will
like make a huge debt in phase six
clearly it looks like they're gonna be
killing off Kings and Loki season two so
I think it's gonna be like a major
figuring out more about the king
variants and maybe their weaknesses that
we didn't really get to see in Quantum
Mania just yet I think that Loki is
going to be a huge one like massive like
every if they keep making low-key
Seasons I think that those seasons will
be the most crucial Seasons to watch
during this Multiverse Saga because this
is the Multiverse Saga and this in Loki
is a very Multiverse Centric show so
yeah I think they're Loki especially
leading into a King Dynasty and Secret
Wars Loki is a must to watch
um if you are a Marvel Studios fan
um so again Disney plus if you know if
you don't have it already oh basically
um but I also think another
um big property that a lot of people are
going to be surprised that
um will factor into space six is
um because like it's a huge massive
Cosmic tale and like we know that
um I would say the Marvels and Guardians
3 together specifically
um mostly because like of the the
mutants that are coming because we know
that the mutants are being set up for um
the for a I don't know if it's gonna be
called the mutant Saga but like a little
bit later down the road that's when
we're gonna get like the X-Men films
um specifically for Marvel Studios and
so with Marvel slowly introducing
mutated people in uh Miss Marvel and um
you know we know the high evolutionary
is going to play a massive role in
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 who and
this whole thing is about Evolution and
human evolution
um these two projects are going to be
crucial to you know moving forward the
the mutant narrative because we see
mutants popping up with Miss Marvel we
saw
that prisoner from a black widow I don't
know why I'm blanking on his name
something bare
um uh the Big Bear a little bear uh from
the from next year
um I don't I'm Blakey on his name it's
bugging a buggy for the rest of this day
um but yeah there was a mutant
introduced in black widow
um so mutants are slowly there's gonna
be mutants most likely introduced in um
Captain America New World Order I think
that was confirmed it says their name
was Ursa Major
I thought is does he doesn't doesn't he
turn into a bear yeah he turns into a
bear yeah yeah yeah I just looked at all
just double check okay I just had a bear
band in my brain I'm like yes Russian
Bear man yes correct but yes I think
that those two projects are going to be
very very crucial to phase six I was
thinking more about like the Guardians
of the Galaxy because the reason why I
felt like it was more gonna make a
hiccup to phase six is more so but yours
is valid yours is sound uh especially
the high evolutionary creating like
restructuring genetics uh I was like
Adam Warlock is still stuck with me I
don't Warlock and like I think the
Marvel's too I think the marbles are
gonna make a huge gem because Captain
Marvel I think should have the ability
to enter the quantum realm with her
powers uh or at least like she's just
like a ball of quanta or some sort of
quantum energy but like there was an
interview with um with Samuel Jackson at
one point
um in the distant past where he he did
say that Captain Mark Marvel has the
ability to time travel which is a very
weird thing for him to say and I was
like what what does that mean and so
like but like until the end of Miss
Marvel when we saw them do that weird
shift I was like oh my goodness what if
like Captain Marvel literally has the
ability to like go through time because
she we saw her
um be able to go through space with um
Miss Marvel I think in the Thunderbolts
ghost will be like in a very important
character I think phase six will be a
lot of Kang uh Kang clearly immortus was
like hey they're entering the Quan or
the Multiverse we gotta stop them before
they they come in here take what's ours
and so I think it's gonna be them going
after people that are really going to
affect the quantum rail or not the
quantum they're really going to affect
the Multiverse so it's people like
America Chavez that can literally jump
them I think it's people like a ghost
that is literally a ball of quantum
energy that can go probably into the
quantum realm and destroy it or create
something that could be just like the uh
energy ball that was made to power
Kang's original ship so I I'm like I
think it's gonna be like people like
that that are going to be very important
in whatever project they're attached to
is going to be completely like a target
for Kang so I think Thunderbolts will be
one of those the marbles has to be one
of those all three of those girls are
literally Targets on their backs of
gangs I think I also think that stands
for Agatha coven of chaos because I'm
very stuck on the witch stuff and the
Kings and I really want to believe there
is a king out there that knows chaos
magic or that studied it or did
something with it and Agatha is one of
those now is now that we don't have the
Scarlet Witch Agatha will have to step
in line as that which to be able to take
him down but we just don't have her yet
because she's in the sunken I would
really love to see a wizard K like that
would be so funny I brought it up that
one time that okay weaponized Elias why
can't we weaponize why couldn't there be
a king that weaponizes the dweller in
darkness and Shang Chi so why can't
there be a king that is technically the
high evolutionary and just uh
restructuring genetics why isn't there a
king that's Victor timely creating just
old like in a different weird time
creating advanced technology I think
there is a king for almost everything
kind of not like the Scrolls but I think
there is a king that probably studied
something in their Universe because they
didn't have access to something else so
like chaos magic was there but not uh
what Doctor Strange studies or something
like it I want to believe there is a
chaos wielding King out there I honestly
think that that's what they were going
for with the Scarlet Centurion
um even though he does look like a robot
they made him a purple robot for a
reason I think there's a little bit of
chaos magic in him much like Agatha
um is purple because I think that
Agatha's purple because it's a mix of
chaos Magic from the dark old and the
Blue Magic from
um the Salem coven
um
person so I think the similar thing
could have be happening with the Scarlet
Centurion which is why they made him
purple and even though he's called The
Scarlet Centurion and Scarlett is red uh
but no I liked all those points though
that would be a super fun way to tackle
Kang and including him into all those
projects
um but I think that a lot of people are
not giving Echoes enough like hype and
praise here because I feel like Echo has
a huge opportunity to continue
um the the specifically the dragon
narrative that shangchi sort of started
and we know because we know that um you
know marvel has um the rights to
um Iron Fist now and I think that with
shengchi introducing dragons and um you
know marvel and having the rights to
Iron Fist I think that Echo is going to
continue this Dragon narrative because
like we know from Hawkeye that she talks
about
um are dragons real and her dad's like I
don't know if dragons are real but but
like who knows maybe we'll talk about
dragons in your own show I think that
Marvel Studios is trying to set up um
with um shanxi Echo and
um
Excalibur okay different dragons from
Earth's past which is basically what I'm
going for sorry
I I think that which is this isn't fair
this is not a fair assumption that I'm
about to make I was feeling like Echo
Daredevil born again even New World
Order
um a little bit of the Thunderbolts
would focus more towards secret Invasion
and the Scrolls and government stuff wow
because we're also I I mentioned this
and I'll mention it again and wakanda
forever they confirmed there's a
president written but we now know that
there is going to be a president
Harrison Ford who is Thunderbolt Ross so
where did President ritzen go if we now
have a new president so I think there's
going to be something there that is
going to be explored and just expanded
on within the government side of
Marvel's Cinematic Universe and then
those are what the superpowers the super
super powers are going to be the king
side and then we all meet in the middle
of course during like phase six when we
reach the secret Wars and the doom shows
up or something I think that's when
everybody has to connect again
um I I I'm so I'm still like visually
I'm obsessed with Echo from the comics
uh I don't know what it looks like on TV
but I I'm very excited for Echo also
because I just want that Echo Daredevil
Vincent D'Onofrio to come back like that
uh relationship of her wanting to kill
Vincent D'Onofrio uh Wilson Fisk that we
got in Hawkeye so I'm very excited for
her I just think she's gonna be kicking
some scroll ass or she's gonna be
witnessing a lot of the people in her
Circle in her freaking Circle
becoming Scrolls and she's gonna be
beating their ass that's what I wrote
that would be bananas that's I would
love to see that I would also love to
see like some type of inclusion with um
like the remnants of the Red Room oh
yeah somewhere there
I know that they're not really in that
in that realm but like I think
tangentially with Hawkeye and black
widow that narrative well the thing is
we still have Taskmaster who was taken
by the the the remaining widows so it's
like what if she does run in the
Taskmaster there is a comic book line of
echo learning to fight by watching
Daredevil and Taskmaster fight all the
time on like a VHS tape so if we have
this experience of her being like I
could kick Daredevil's ass and I'll kick
your ass and it's just the Taskmaster
Daredevil and Echo fighting it out uh is
a possibility it's a possibility
we still there's a lot of people in the
MCU that we still haven't met there's
still a lot of MCU people from phase
four that need to come over into phase
five they need to trickle in even if
we're bringing it we still have yeah
like a big wheel we're talking about big
wheel right I need big wheel to show up
in a Spider-Man 4 movie all right big
wheel is one of the most incredible
Spider-Man villains Sony I need you to
look up big wheels put him in the
Spiderman never bring it up again uh put
it in across the spider verse and never
uh we still have we still have a lot of
people we never got the resolve of like
shangshi's ending with his sister now
taking over for his dad's Empire we
still know that Wonder man's coming we
still haven't got Nova and but we know
that it's coming we know that it's
coming so there's so many things to be
excited for in Phase five that hopefully
we'll get hopefully Jeff loveness will
flush out for phase six because we know
that he's going from quantumania to Kang
Dynasty
um there's so much there's so much to be
excited for why can't you not be excited
no no like this is going to be like
super super high phase five is going to
be super dope in setting up like um
continuing the Multiverse narrative and
phase six like we only got a small
Sweden of what SpaceX is gonna look like
but like you know phase six is gonna
have that Nova project because like they
set it up in Infinity war and we've got
to see that come to do come through
fruition
um eventually and projects we didn't
really talk too much about like blade is
still coming it's a lot of things have
been shifted but shifted for reasons
shifted to come back and make us even
happier with the product so we still
have blade that's still coming
um they pushed what if but it's probably
coming sooner or later yeah what if he's
like one of my personal really high like
anticipated projects because like what
if season one was incredible seeing
killmonger Infinity almost take it all
oh my God yes incredible wait so I have
what if we still got blade we still have
iron heart coming it got pushed a little
bit but it's still on the way and
everybody should be excited because
she's amazing she's my favorite
character yes so make sure to tune in
make sure to be there and then watch our
breakdown is our in our coverage and our
theories on every single one and that is
it for this episode of inside Marvel
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel at Deep dive in our follow me at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow uh Mt at
mastertainment follow Eric Voss at EA
boss he couldn't be here today because
he's doing so much Star Wars stuff for
you guys he's doing Mandalorian he's
doing everything he's breaking it down
he's doing Wikileaks he's doing
everything he's interviewing people he's
always doing too much subscribe to
inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast and we'll see you guys again
next week bye bye guys
[Music]
thank you